I know I know I haven't posted a video
in a couple of weeks but if you followed
me on my Twitter or my instagrams you
would have known that you disloyal
[ __ ]
just kidding let's do this hey what is
going on YouTube well you're cute
bastards today we are gonna go through
some articles and some [ __ ] that you
guys sent me that we're gonna talk about
your cute little nipple bunnies first up
we have Texas butthole tickling bandit
finally caught okay first of all I know
that this article isn't real but I'm
going to entertain it like it is because
it's [ __ ] hilarious even before I
check the validity of this article
multiple articles stated that this man
who they thought was homeless wasn't
homeless and actually he was caught with
4500 dollars worth of Yeezy clothing I
mean come on I'm not saying that this
[ __ ] can't happen but if it can I'm
saying I don't want to live in a world
where this [ __ ] exists I'm not trying to
wake up one day and have a crackhead
look of a loose change in my [ __ ]
nope that's pity sense right deal there
is absolutely no way I could talk to my
friends after something traumatizing
like that so you can share stories to
your peers about getting your ass beat
that's fine
what happened your face got my ass beat
why you cannot share a story about a man
who used your booty crevice as a
makeshift piggy bank you have any idea
how defensive you will get with your
friends a [ __ ] happen to yo and what
about my ass [ __ ]
alright what the [ __ ] I'm just saying
nobody [ __ ] my ass all I'm saying is
that you get your butt tickled by a
crackhead that [ __ ] goes to the grave
with you and to quote some of these
made-up victims family on my back every
day and now I could finally sleep on my
stomach again well maybe you wouldn't
get your imaginary bud tickled if you
didn't sleep with your ass cheeks spread
out like you was trying to smuggle some
illegal goods
next up Mexican bullfighter was gored so
far up his ass he needs to get his
rectum fully reconstructed take a look
at this [ __ ]
oh you don't [ __ ] with bulls man see
when most people see a large animal that
resembles the devil you usually run away
but the Spanish people are like alright
just as a general rule if you don't want
to piss off an animal that makes it two
hundred and forty five pound Korean man
look like a little [ __ ] I'll tell you
right now that bull knew exactly what he
was doing the economy the booty badness
if you notice in this picture the dude
basically gets a horn forced up his ass
the size of my arm with the force of a
thousand suns what all you fools send me
ass [ __ ] articles today what's what's
it what's the theme here all it takes is
one mistake and you get your [ __ ]
duty hole turned inside out
apparently the bullfighter Antonio
Romero got his ass gored so hard the
bull left a 12-inch laceration in his
[ __ ] meaning that after today he
could literally [ __ ] bricks if he wanted
to Antonio you could probably sit
directly on a broom and you wouldn't
even know the difference but looking on
the bright side from now on when you
take a [ __ ] it's gonna take like half a
second just just as a general rule you
don't piss off a creature on purpose
purpose the [ __ ] is perfect
Oh perfect